Der zoe
3200 phaeton ist schon seit 30 jahren bekannt doch trotzdem
Stellt der astronomie teams noch immer vor riesige rätsel denn er benimmt sich ganz und gar nicht wie ein gewöhnlicher astrid
nicht nur seine umlaufbahn ist mehr als
außergewöhnlich und jetzt kommt uns 3200 phaeton mitte dezember tatsächlich sehr nahe ob diese riesige gesteinsbrocken
Überhaupt wirklich ein asteroid ist was er mit dem sternschnuppen regen mit der dezember zu tun hat und wie die nasa die großen rätsel um
3200 phaeton lösen will jetzt den blick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Sein steckbrief klingt erst einmal alles andere als besonders außergewöhnlich 3000 seiner väter und hat einen durchmesser von etwa fünf kilometern
Seine form ist kugelförmig alle 3,6 stunden rotierte einmal um seine eigene achse
Er gehört mit zu den erdnahen asteroiden die potenziell eine gefahr für die erde darstellen könnten unter ihnen ist
3200 phaeton der drittgrößte am 16 dezember 2017 ist es dann soweit der street wird mit einem abstand von nur
0,06 9 astronomischen einheiten an der erde vorbeifliegen das entspricht etwa einem abstand von zehn millionen kilometern
also
Wirklich nah ist dass nicht jemand zum vergleich unser mond ist 27 mal weiter von uns entfernt doch mit
Großen radioteleskopen ist 3200 phaeton dann von der erde aus wirklich gut zu beobachten
Mit hilfe von radar wellen wie die nasa aufnahmen von den mysteriöse nass
zu ihnen machen damit soll dann ein sehr genaues 3d modell erstellt werden denn es sind gleich mehrere rätsel vdi und
3200 phaeton stellt und das obwohl er uns schon so lange bekannt ist fangen wir an mit seiner merkwürdigen
Umlaufbahn die ist ellison für mich und das ist für den großteil der asteroiden äußerst außergewöhnlich normalerweise kreisen sie ja auf einer
kreisrunden bahn anders dagegen
3200 phaeton damit ihr es euch besser vorstellen könnt seien per e mail
also seinen sonnennächsten punkt liegt alle 14 jahre extrem dicht an der sonne nämlich doppelt
So nah wie der merkur der innerste planet genauer gesagt die 3200 phaeton dann rund 20 millionen kilometer also
0,4 10 astronomische einheiten von der sonne entfernt deswegen auch sein name phaeton der sohn des sonnengottes
helios sein sonnenfenster punkt dagegen liegt sogar
Außerhalb der mars umlaufbahn der ja unser äußerer nachbar ist kurz noch einen kleinen fun fact
Zu seinen namen der ihn als den sohn des sonnengottes, helios bezeichnet in der griechischen mythologie
Vernichtet vätern die erde fast denn er setzt sie in feuer schon ein bisschen unheimlich aber ich kann euch beruhigen das wird mit dem dezember
Nicht passieren wenn man die umlaufbahn von 3200 phaeton betrachtet fällt auf dass sie also eher
Kometen ist sie passt zudem sehr genau zu der umlaufbahn des meteorstrom der geminiden
Sternschnuppen deswegen gibt es die vermutung dass es sich bei dem asteroiden um ihre mutter körper handelt doch das ist das zweite große rätsel um
3200 phaeton denn wie ihr vielleicht wisst bringen asteroiden normalerweise keine sternschnuppen hervor
stattdessen werden dafür kometen verantwortlich gemacht lockerer von eis verpacker staub löst sich bei jeder runde um die sonne und
das bildet dann den strahlenden schweif und die sternschnuppen die bei uns in der atmosphäre verglühten das ist die drag spur also der schweiz
Der im weltraum zurück bleibt und uns mit den sternschnuppen wünsche beschert handelt es sich bei
3200 phaeton also eher um einen kometen manche forschungsteams vermuten tatsächlich dass es sich um einen ausgebrannten
Kometenkern handel demnach wäre der meteorstrom der geminiden
Aus alten zeiten des ehemaligen kometen von damals also also noch aktiv war apropos aktiv es gibt tatsächlich
Beobachtungen nach dem 3200 phaeton ab und an aktiv ist bei
Den gelegentlichen ausbrüchen des asteroiden werden hin und wieder kleine partikel frei doch fest steht auch
Er besteht aus einer festen und steinernen oberfläche ganz so wie man es von typischen us ihnen kennt und das wissen wir alle
Das ist ganz und gar ein wirklich ungeeignetes material für sternschnuppen das rätsel um 3000 tonnen fett
Ist tatsächlich groß es gibt das solo mit teams die seine extreme
Nähe zur sonne als problem ansehen demnach beeinflusst die gigantische gravitation der sonne
3200 phaeton so sehr dass er langsam
Zerschreddert wird fest steht jedenfalls mitte dezember wird uns der mysteriöse gesteinsbrocken dann ganz nah sein und alle die ein
Teleskop haben werden ihnen vielleicht sogar selbst sehen können links vom sternbild pegasus und zwar in der ersten
Nachthälfte in den nächten vorher gibt es auf jeden fall die geminiden also den sternschnuppen regen, am himmel
zu sehen und vielleicht wissen wir mitte dezember mehr wenn die nasa dann die großen rätsel um
3200 phaeton
Vielleicht lösen kann wenn ihr kein video dazu und auch
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann durch media ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke nur dann verpasst er kein video her also hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken hast du jeden bedrohen die erde jederzeit
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt hat